Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. I'm joined by Dr. Thomas Insel, a psychiatrist and neuroscientist, whose co-founder and president of Mind Strong Health, a company that is using mobile technology to diagnose and treat behavioral health disorders. Prior to Mindstrong, Dr. Insel was a longtime director of the National Institute of Mental Health. Welcome, Dr. Insel. Thank you, Caitlin. Pleasure to be here.
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天做客节目的嘉宾是精神病学家兼神经科学家托马斯·因塞尔博士，他是Mindstrong Health公司的联合创始人兼总裁，该公司正利用移动技术来诊断和治疗行为健康障碍。在加入Mindstrong之前，因塞尔博士曾长期担任美国国家心理健康研究所所长。欢迎您，因塞尔博士。谢谢你，凯特琳。很高兴来到这里。
Thank you for joining us today. So at the 2018 APA Convention, you gave a talk with a provocative title called Smartphones Are A Problem, Can They Be a Solution? And every day we hear about how smartphones are impacting our attention spans, relationships, a number of things, our health overall. But they're really our lifelines. We use them to get wherever we need to go, whatever we need. So how can they be a solution if they are a problem? Well, Caitlin, the way that you frame that, I think, is exactly the way we think about it. They have become a lifeline.
感谢您今天参加我们的节目。在2018年的美国心理学会年会上，您发表了一场题为《智能手机是个问题，它们能成为解决方案吗？》的演讲，这个标题非常引人深思。我们每天都能听到关于智能手机如何影响我们的注意力、人际关系、方方面面以及整体健康的消息。但它们确实是我们的生命线。我们需要去任何地方、需要任何东西时都会用到它们。那么，如果它们本身就是个问题，又怎么能成为解决方案呢？嗯，凯特琳，我认为你提出的这个框架，正是我们思考问题的方式。它们确实已经成为了生命线。
They become a way that we navigate the world. It's probably not too strong to say that we live on our phones or we live through our phones. Not making a value judgment here, but that is, for better or worse, the state of play for most people, especially younger people in the U.S. and increasingly around the world. In behavioral health broadly, we've spent much of the last five decades trying to understand how to measure how people are doing. And the way we usually do that is we say, how are you feeling? In the hopes that we will get from them a reply that will help us to assess their level of
它们成了我们在这个世界上导航的方式。说我们生活在手机里，或者通过手机生活，这恐怕并不夸张。我在这里不做价值判断，但无论好坏，这就是大多数人的现状，尤其是美国乃至全球各地的年轻人。在广义的行为健康领域，过去五十年来，我们大部分时间都在努力理解如何衡量人们的状态。我们通常的做法是问：“你感觉怎么样？”希望他们能给我们一个回复，帮助我们评估他们过去几天、几周或几个月的
functioning over the previous days, weeks, or months, for the first time, we actually have a way of looking directly at how they're functioning by using the device that is their lifeline, that is the way in which they're living. We've never been able to do that before, and smartphones give us this kind of unprecedented opportunity to get a window directly into how somebody's functioning without having to use a paper and pencil test, without having to get them to guesstimate for us, like with the PHQ9, how they've been feeling over the previous two weeks. We can actually look every day over the previous two weeks and know exactly how they're doing
功能水平。现在，我们第一次可以通过他们赖以生存的设备，也就是他们生活的方式，直接观察他们的功能状态。我们以前从未做到过这一点。智能手机为我们提供了一个前所未有的机会，让我们能直接洞察某人的功能状态，而无需使用纸笔测试，也不必让他们像填写PHQ-9量表那样去猜测过去两周的感受。我们实际上可以查看过去两周的每一天，并确切地知道他们的表现
in terms of how they're managing the world around them. And can you walk us through the Mindstrong apps? You're talking about what we'll know from those apps. Can you tell me how they work? What Mindstrong did was actually not to begin around behavioral health. The birth of the company came about because our founder, Paul Daigam, was in a different realm altogether. He was in cybersecurity.
以及他们如何应对周围的世界。您能为我们介绍一下Mindstrong的应用程序吗？您提到了我们能从这些应用中了解到什么。能告诉我它们是如何工作的吗？Mindstrong所做的其实并不是从行为健康领域开始的。这家公司的诞生是因为我们的创始人保罗·戴加姆（Paul Dagum）当时处于一个完全不同的领域。他从事的是网络安全工作。
the question he was posing was in cybersecurity, is there a way to track hackers? Is there a way to identify individuals, not by how they are posting a username or where their address is, but by how they type? And he was able to develop that. It's a tool now called behavioral analytics, very important in the forensic area of cybersecurity.
他在网络安全领域提出的问题是：有没有办法追踪黑客？有没有办法识别个人，不是通过他们发布用户名或地址的方式，而是通过他们的打字方式？他成功开发出了这种工具。这现在被称为行为分析，在网络安全的取证领域非常重要。
And Paul developed this with a hope of being able to create a sort of robust, mechanism for identifying individuals. He called it a digital fingerprint. When his company was bought and he was looking for the next opportunity to use digital fingerprinting, he thought maybe we could use this in healthcare. His background was as a physician. He was in a previous career, a cardiovascular surgeon.
保罗开发这个工具的初衷是希望能够建立一种强大的个人识别机制。他称之为“数字指纹”。当他的公司被收购，他寻找下一个利用数字指纹技术的机会时，他想也许我们可以将其用于医疗保健。他的背景是一名医生。他之前的职业是一名心血管外科医生。
And so he took this digital fingerprinting idea and began using it in the company that's now called Mindstrong for digital phenotyping. What is that? It's very simple. It's using a measure through an app of how someone interacts with their keyboard. It's the taps, it's the scrolls, it's the clicks, it's all of that, and measuring that across time to create a set of potential biomarkers that have then been developed by taking hundreds actually now thousands of people and at the same time using gold standard reference tools,
于是，他将这种数字指纹识别的想法带到了现在名为Mindstrong的公司，用于数字表型分析。那是什么？很简单。它通过应用程序测量某人与键盘的交互方式。包括点击、滚动、按压，所有这些动作，并随时间进行测量，从而创建出一套潜在的生物标志物。这些标志物是通过对数百人，实际上现在是数千人进行研究，并同时使用黄金标准参考工具开发出来的，
whether that is the PHQ9 or a Hamilton Depression score or whether it's a not. neurocognitive battery or even now doing the same kind of thing with neuroimaging trying to find ways to validate those signals against gold standard measures and begin to say do we have a way currently to use this smartphone device to use these tools to begin to say rather than having you to fill out a form every other day or every week maybe we could get continuous objective passive measurement from the way you interact with your phone, not what you type, but how you type. That's what Mind Strong is all about. And how does that work? How does your swiping behavior
无论是PHQ-9量表、汉密尔顿抑郁量表，还是神经认知测试，甚至是现在利用神经影像学做同样的事情，试图找到验证这些信号的方法，并开始探讨：我们目前是否有办法利用智能手机设备和这些工具，不再需要你每隔一天或每周填写一份表格，而是通过你与手机的交互方式——不是你输入的内容，而是你输入的方式——来获取持续、客观、被动的测量数据？这就是Mindstrong的核心所在。那它是如何工作的呢？你的滑动行为如何
show that you might be experiencing depression or something even more serious? Yeah, it's an interesting question. One would think that those two things would be unrelated. What we're discovering is that in the same way that we say, this is your lifeline, this is how you navigate the world, that the way you do that is reflected in changes in mood. Now, if that sounds surprising, and maybe it should be, I should point out that there's not a single measure. It's not as if we've simply said, oh, you know, the delay between hitting the space bar
显示你可能正在经历抑郁症或更严重的问题？是的，这是一个有趣的问题。人们可能会认为这两者是不相关的。我们发现，正如我们所说，这是你的生命线，是你在这个世界上导航的方式，而你这样做的方式反映在情绪的变化中。如果这听起来令人惊讶，也许确实应该如此，我应该指出，并没有单一的衡量标准。并不是说我们简单地认为，哦，你敲击空格键
and a character on the smartphone is the same as whatever your Hamilton Depression score will be, or it's a predictor of relapse. It's not like that. are a thousand potential biomarkers. There are hundreds that go together through machine learning to create the panel that we call a digital biomarker. And those, there's not one single event
和智能手机上字符之间的延迟，就等同于你的汉密尔顿抑郁评分，或者它是复发的预测指标。不是那样的。有上千种潜在的生物标志物。通过机器学习，有数百种标志物结合在一起，形成了我们所说的“数字生物标志物”面板。而且，并不是手机上的某一个单一事件
or one single operation on the phone that is predictive, it's a whole range of those put together. And interestingly, we can customize this. So as you might expect, the signals are a little bit different if you're 73 instead of 23, if you live in China, versus living in the United States. So part of the work of Mindstrong is identifying those signals in a customized, robust way that provides
或某一个单一操作具有预测性，而是将一系列操作结合在一起。有趣的是，我们可以对其进行定制。正如你所料，如果你是73岁而不是23岁，如果你住在中国而不是美国，信号会略有不同。因此，Mindstrong的工作部分在于以一种定制化、稳健的方式识别这些信号，从而提供
some clinically actionable signal that we can use for healthcare. And for someone who's listening and watching, who doesn't have a background in science, what is a biomarker briefly? Yeah, a biomarker. We know biomarkers mostly through the rest of medicine. So in diabetes care, we used to use glucose. Now we use something called the hemoglobin A1C.
一些临床上可操作的信号，供医疗保健使用。对于正在收听和观看、没有科学背景的人来说，简而言之，什么是生物标志物？是的，生物标志物。我们主要通过其他医学领域了解生物标志物。例如在糖尿病护理中，我们过去使用血糖，现在我们使用一种叫做糖化血红蛋白（HbA1c）的指标。
In the case of monitoring your hypertension, we look at blood pressure, it's a biomarker. For prostate cancer, we have the PSA. We have a whole range of tests in medicine, often blood-based tests that we use as objective, robust measures that tell us how somebody is progressing in the course of their illness or whether they meet the criteria for an illness.
在监测高血压时，我们看血压，这就是一种生物标志物。对于前列腺癌，我们有PSA。医学上有各种各样的测试，通常是基于血液的测试，我们将其作为客观、稳健的衡量标准，告诉我们某人的病情进展如何，或者他们是否符合某种疾病的诊断标准。
Part of what's really been a handicap for us in the whole realm of mental illness, is that we do not have biomarkers at this point that are clinically useful. There's been a tremendous amount of research around this, looking for markers in blood, markers in the brain through imaging. We still lack anything that has a clinical validity to it as a biomarker for either diagnosis or for monitoring care. The hope here is that by using the smartphone, we can begin to find those signals
在整个心理健康领域，一直困扰我们的一点是，我们目前还没有临床上有用的生物标志物。围绕这一领域进行了大量的研究，寻找血液中的标志物，通过影像学寻找大脑中的标志物。我们仍然缺乏任何具有临床有效性的生物标志物，无论是用于诊断还是监测护理。这里的希望在于，通过使用智能手机，我们可以开始找到那些信号，
that actually will do for different things. depression and PTSD and schizophrenia, what the hemoglobin A1C has done for diabetes. And so if the app has indicated that you might be suffering from depression, what's next? What is the next step? Does Mindstrong tell you what to do? Yeah, that's absolutely the best question, Caitlin, because we often call these biomarkers, these digital signals, we call them digital smoke alarms. I mean, basically it's telling you that there's a problem.
这些信号实际上能为抑郁症、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）和精神分裂症等不同疾病发挥作用，就像糖化血红蛋白对糖尿病所做的那样。那么，如果应用程序显示你可能患有抑郁症，接下来该怎么办？下一步是什么？Mindstrong会告诉你该怎么做吗？是的，这绝对是最好的问题，凯特琳，因为我们经常把这些生物标志物、这些数字信号称为“数字烟雾报警器”。我的意思是，它基本上是在告诉你出了问题，
problem that needs attention. That's important, it's not enough, right? It tells you that you need to do something. So what do you do? And what Mind Strong is involved with now is creating what we often call the efferent loop, not just the affront loop, but hey, there's a smoke signal here, but actually doing something to put out the fire.
一个需要关注的问题。这很重要，但还不够，对吧？它告诉你需要采取行动。那么你该做什么呢？Mindstrong现在所参与的，正是创建我们常说的“传出回路”，不仅仅是“传入回路”，即“嘿，这里有烟雾信号”，而是真正采取行动去灭火。
What would that be? Well, in our case, we have the advantage, again, of having a platform, which everybody carries around in their pocket. and which allows us not only to detect a problem, but to deliver solutions. Those solutions could be a form of psychotherapy, it could be a form of education,
那会是什么呢？嗯，就我们而言，我们再次拥有一个优势，即拥有一个每个人都随身携带的平台。它不仅允许我们检测问题，还能提供解决方案。这些解决方案可以是心理治疗，也可以是教育，
it could be a form of connecting people to care so that it could be helpful not just for online, but offline care. There's a whole range of resources that you can deliver through the phone so that people have access to them in real time that allow you to provide what we would call not only measurement-based care, but connected care.
它可以是将人们与护理联系起来的一种方式，这样不仅对在线护理有帮助，对线下护理也有帮助。通过手机可以提供一系列资源，让人们能够实时获取，从而提供我们所说的不仅是基于测量的护理，更是互联的护理。
So it keeps in touch with people, and it connects people to the resources either online or offline that can make a difference once they're developing a problem. And so cybersecurity is a big issue, and you talked about people within your organization, your president, co-president, who was a background in that. So can you talk about cybersecurity? What do you say to people who might be worried about, okay, you're getting in my phone, like, what I worry about their data, what do you say to that? Well, it certainly helps to have a founder who's got great expertise in security and knowing how to handle questions around privacy. There are several issues here, a deep dive, and certainly we're in this era where so many
所以它能与人们保持联系，并将人们与在线或线下的资源连接起来，一旦他们出现问题，这些资源就能发挥作用。网络安全是一个大问题，你谈到了你们组织内部的人员，你的总裁、联合总裁，他们有这方面的背景。那么你能谈谈网络安全吗？对于那些可能担心“好吧，你们进入了我的手机，我担心我的数据”的人，你会怎么说？嗯，有一位在安全领域拥有丰富专业知识并了解如何处理隐私问题的创始人，这肯定很有帮助。这里有几个问题，需要深入探讨，我们当然处于这样一个时代，
of us have been burnt by bad behavior from tech companies. We often now talk about the tech lash, the backlash against tech companies because of the way they have mishandled our personal data or people have been miseducated about what would happen to their data. So at our company, most of the companies in this mental health space, and there are many now, this has become a major focus of figuring out how to do this with public trust,
我们中的许多人都被科技公司的不良行为伤害过。我们现在经常谈论“科技抵制”（tech lash），即由于科技公司处理个人数据不当，或者人们被误导了数据会发生什么，而对科技公司产生的强烈抵制。因此，在我们的公司，以及这个心理健康领域的许多公司中，这已经成为一个主要焦点，即如何以公众信任的方式做到这一点，
how to do this with tight security, with data protection. There are of course new regulations like the GDPR in Europe or the new California consumer privacy law that just passed last month here in California. We've gone way beyond those to make sure that the data that we collect is not only encrypted but it's doubly protected and most of all it's set up in such a way that if someone is
如何以严密的安全性、数据保护来做到这一点。当然，现在有了新的法规，比如欧洲的《通用数据保护条例》（GDPR），或者上个月在加州刚刚通过的新的《加州消费者隐私法》。我们已经远远超出了这些要求，以确保我们收集的数据不仅是加密的，而且是双重保护的，最重要的是，它的设置方式是，如果有人
uncomfortable with what's happening with their data they have full agency full opportunity to be able to withdraw so this is all about building a system that's not only effective in terms of its clinical value but it's earns public trust because it provides transparency It cares about privacy and security. And most of all, it confers agency to the people whose data you're collecting. Those together, I think, can help us.
对他们数据的处理感到不舒服，他们拥有完全的自主权，完全有机会撤回。所以这一切都是为了建立一个系统，不仅在临床价值方面有效，而且能赢得公众信任，因为它提供了透明度，关心隐私和安全。最重要的是，它赋予了数据被收集者以自主权。我认为，这些结合在一起可以帮助我们。
What we've said is our North Star at Mindstrong is the idea that we're empowering patients and families by giving them better data. And I think if we keep that as the North Star, as the way that we wanna build a product that really helps people by giving them the best data we can give them. I think that actually goes a long way to building public trust.
我们所说的是，Mindstrong的北极星目标是：通过为患者和家庭提供更好的数据来赋能他们。我认为，如果我们保持这一目标作为北极星，作为我们想要构建产品的方式，通过提供我们能给出的最好数据来真正帮助人们，我认为这对于建立公众信任大有裨益。
And so can you talk about how apps like this improve health care, mental health care and then health care overall? You know, it's an interesting point in time. I think we're still early on in what will be, I think, a very exciting story. We may be in chapter one or chapter two, where many apps and many companies have shown the feasibility and shown the power of the signals they can create or the very very very. value of the interventions they can deliver through the smartphone. What we don't know at this point is what the impact of this new technology will be on public
那么你能谈谈像这样的应用程序如何改善医疗保健、心理健康护理，进而改善整体医疗保健吗？你知道，这是一个有趣的时刻。我认为我们还处于一个非常激动人心的故事的早期阶段。我们可能处于第一章或第二章，许多应用程序和公司已经证明了可行性，证明了它们可以产生的信号的力量，或者它们可以通过智能手机提供的干预措施的价值。我们目前不知道的是，这种新技术将对公共
health. We haven't yet had the deployment to millions or multi-millions of people in need to be able to say, hey, this decreases suicide. This reduces hospitalization and emergency room visits. This reduces the cost while improving the quality of care and giving us better outcomes. All of us want that. All of us are on that path. But I'd say here at the beginning of August 2018, we're not there yet. And so I believe you probably just answered my last question about just double track.
健康产生什么影响。我们还没有将其部署到数百万或数千万有需要的人群中，从而能够说：“嘿，这降低了自杀率。这减少了住院和急诊次数。这在提高护理质量并提供更好结果的同时降低了成本。”我们所有人都想要那样。我们都在这条道路上。但我得说，在2018年8月初的现在，我们还没有达到那个阶段。我想你可能刚刚回答了我关于双轨制的最后一个问题。
Is this the future of health care? And if so, what are the limitations? What are the benefits? What are the limitations? Yeah, so what an interesting time we're in. I think it's fair to say that health care will be changing. and in some ways we're slow to this change. And retail and entertainment and banking and so much of our society has already been transformed
这是医疗保健的未来吗？如果是，局限性是什么？好处是什么？局限性是什么？嗯，我们正处于一个多么有趣的时代。我认为可以公平地说，医疗保健将会发生变化，在某些方面我们对这种变化的反应很慢。零售、娱乐、银行以及我们社会的许多方面都已经
by this digital and information revolution. It hasn't happened for health care. And maybe that's not surprising. Maybe we should have expected that health care would be a little slow to the party. the fact that Amazon and Berkshire Hathaway and J.P. Morgan and now come together to say, hey, we want to look at health care, and we want to try to provide something that gets better outcomes at lower costs and is more acceptable to our employees. That's interesting. And I think we'll see over the next
被这场数字和信息革命所改变。医疗保健领域还没有发生这种情况。也许这并不令人惊讶。也许我们本应预料到医疗保健在参与变革方面会慢一些。事实上，亚马逊、伯克希尔·哈撒韦公司和摩根大通现在联合起来说：“嘿，我们想看看医疗保健，我们想尝试提供一些能以更低成本获得更好结果，并且更受员工欢迎的东西。”这很有趣。我认为在接下来的
couple of years that those companies and many others are going to begin to transform the way health care gets delivered. My guess is at the end of the day, we're not talking about a completely online system, not only because we need to have surgical centers, we need ICUs, we need to have hospitals where people can get intensive care. But even for mental health care, it's likely that we will have both online and offline. And I think the future of mental health care is going to be both high tech and high touch. How we put those together and how we build both the high tech and a better high touch system is going to be really interesting.
几年里，我们会看到这些公司和其他许多公司将开始改变医疗保健的交付方式。我的猜测是，归根结底，我们谈论的不是一个完全在线的系统，不仅是因为我们需要手术中心、重症监护室，我们需要人们可以获得重症监护的医院。但即使对于心理健康护理，我们也很有可能同时拥有在线和线下两种方式。我认为心理健康护理的未来将是高科技与高接触并存。我们如何将两者结合起来，以及我们如何建立既有高科技又有更好高接触的系统，将是非常有趣的。
And we're going to see that over the next four or five years. Mind Strong is one of many companies pushing on this high tech side. But we recognize as well that tech is only going to go so far and that when you're dealing with people with serious mental illness, you've got to have the high touch piece as well. What we're banking on is that we can use the tech to get much better. high touch and that I think will be the future of the mental health care system and the way that we're going to build it so I do have one more question was not add one more I know I said it's my last so where is Mindstrong at this point where are you right now and when
我们将在未来四五年内看到这一点。Mindstrong是推动这一高科技方面的众多公司之一。但我们也认识到，技术只能走这么远，当你处理患有严重精神疾病的人时，你也必须有高接触的部分。我们所依赖的是，我们可以利用技术来获得更好的高接触，我认为这将是心理健康护理系统的未来，也是我们将要构建它的方式。所以我还有一个问题，我知道我说过这是最后一个，那么Mindstrong目前处于什么阶段？你们现在在哪里？什么时候
will it is it is it available for people that where are you right so Mindstrong is a work in progress it's a company that's a little over a year old year and a half old although it has about four or five years of data behind it we are building the company through partnerships with mostly at this point health care providers and payers. So our interest is in creating a new healthcare company for mental health that will use technology. We don't provide a consumer device or a consumer app. Though the app is on the Play Store and it's on the App Store, it's not really set up for downloading for individuals to use for themselves.
它对人们可用吗？你们在哪里？好的，Mindstrong是一个正在进行的项目。这是一家成立一年多、一年半左右的公司，尽管它背后有大约四五年的数据支持。我们正在通过与目前主要是医疗保健提供者和支付方的合作来建立公司。因此，我们的兴趣在于为心理健康创建一个使用技术的新型医疗保健公司。我们不提供消费者设备或消费者应用程序。虽然该应用程序在Play商店和App Store上都有，但它并不是真正为个人下载使用而设置的。
We want to use this within a healthcare setting, and so it's available through the research we're currently doing and the partnerships we currently have with a range of both academics for research and the partners that are payers and providers for actually testing out what this does in healthcare. Sounds like there's some exciting times ahead. Super exciting, and you know,
我们希望在医疗保健环境中使用它，因此它可以通过我们目前正在进行的研究以及我们目前与一系列学术界（用于研究）和支付方及提供方（用于实际测试其在医疗保健中的作用）的合作伙伴关系来获得。听起来未来会有一些激动人心的时刻。超级令人兴奋，而且你知道，
I think for a lot of members of the APA, particularly for students, who were thinking like what's my future all about, it's important to recognize that this is a moment in time where the sands are shifting in the same way that a decade ago that would have been true for retail, for entertainment, for many aspects of our economy. That's happening now in healthcare and in mental health care.
我认为对于许多美国心理学会的成员，特别是对于那些思考“我的未来会怎样”的学生来说，重要的是要认识到，这是一个沙子正在移动的时刻，就像十年前零售、娱乐、我们经济的许多方面的情况一样。这种情况现在正在医疗保健和心理健康护理领域发生。
You know, Bill Gates famously said that things will change much less than we expect in the next two years and much more than we expect in the next 10. And I think that's true for mental health care and technology as well. Well, thank you so much for joining us today. Thank you, Caitlin. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology.
你知道，比尔·盖茨曾有名言说，未来两年内事情的变化会比我们预期的要少得多，而未来十年内变化会比我们预期的要多得多。我认为这对心理健康护理和技术来说也是如此。好吧，非常感谢您今天参加我们的节目。谢谢你，凯特琳。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，如《美国心理学会期刊对话》，探讨最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，以及关于心理学实践的《进度记录》。
You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, and wherever you find your podcasts. You can also visit speakingof psychology.org to view other episodes and resources about the topics we do. discuss. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在iTunes、Stitcher以及任何您收听播客的地方找到我们的播客。您也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org查看其他剧集和关于我们讨论主题的资源。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。